today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
welcome everybody special welcome to all
of our new audio podcast subscribers
record week uh yesterday was the best
day the audio podcast has ever had
uh unbelievable and want to welcome
everybody who is
carrying the show around with them in
their pocket i guess as i call it
um we have so much to talk about and
because there's been so much to talk
about we really have not spent as much
time as we should be spending on
coronavirus
and i would be doing a disservice to you
if i didn't do that today
and remember donald trump said that
there would be no more talk of
coronavirus
on november 4th because it was merely
political trump said everything was
going to open on november 4th
trump said there would be no more
discussions of an urgent pandemic on
november 4th of course
it's been the exact opposite in fact and
joe biden has fortunately immediately
formed a coronavirus
task force which has already met we have
continued to talk about it
and coronavirus is completely out of
control there's
there's no other way to say it it's
completely outrageous dystopian numbers
when you look at them and
this administration is done so our
approach going in
is if we don't do something and if
governors don't do something until joe
biden
is inaugurated trump is done trump is in
a fragile emotional state as philip
rucker will later tell us
he is done with the virus now meanwhile
the united states hit a record number of
hospitalizations
this week we passed 1 million new cases
in just
10 days the first 10 days of november
this is exploding and the first two
spikes
in april and july when you look at a
case graph
they barely even look like spikes the
current third spike during which we're
seeing
even 140 000 new cases per day
makes those early spikes in april and
july
look like little mole hills and of
course they were major spikes at the
time
and dr anthony fauci warned us about
this months ago
dr fauci said you could see a hundred
thousand cases a day in the fall
and when we got to 35 000 in april and
they started declining
a lot of people didn't believe dr fauci
but he was right and if anything he
wasn't
aggressive enough because we are seeing
140 000 per day
no sign of a slowdown deaths are also
spiking we've now had two days in a row
with right around
1500 deaths per day that's a 911 every
two days and those numbers are going to
go higher deaths today remember
are based on cases two to three weeks
ago
two to three weeks ago we had half the
cases that we do today
so in two to three more weeks we could
be seeing 2 500 deaths a day
we could be seeing 3 000 deaths a day
not out of the question
we could be seeing a 911 every single
day
right now 49 out of 50 states are
increasing in cases 30 states
set new records just this week and like
i said
hospitalization there were a couple
weeks there
where cases were going up
hospitalizations were not yet up
um hospitalizations have now reached a
pandemic high
and are clearly going higher since 140
000 more people tested positive
yesterday
and the day before um in i'm trying to
think what state it was i believe it's
in one of the dakotas
uh the governor has announced that oh
must
well must be north dakota because south
dakota is christy gnome and this was a
male
governor i believe it's the governor of
north dakota i should be more prepared
i'm going from memory
said hospitals are now full and they
are going to need nurses to keep working
even if they have coronavirus
nurses with coronavirus in again i
believe it's north dakota
have been cleared to keep working even
when they test positive because things
are that out of control
we need leadership i know it's easy to
say listen david
every country is having a spike every
country is seeing a spike
remember that many countries are on
spike two right now
so when we look at other countries and
we see they are also having record
numbers
they are having record numbers rel
related to spike number one
many of those countries suppress the
second spike all summer
and they are now getting to the second
spike we're already on spike number
three
and spike number three is putting spike
number two to shame
all these other countries are only now
getting to spike number two
and um when we say everything is spiking
understand that we are a f i'm not
calling them waves because we never
really got out of wave one but
spikes we are a full spike ahead of most
of these countries and it is an absolute
and total disaster
cdc now issuing recommendations about
thanksgiving and those recommendations
are have thanksgiving outside
now in much of the country it's not
possible uh the dakotas minnesota
northern michigan
you know it gets very very cold here in
massachusetts
it may well be a high of 30 by the time
of thanksgiving even though it's been
unseasonably warm so a lot of people i
know
are either not doing thanksgiving or
they are doing a drastically
reduced thanksgiving i know a few folks
who said
we we're doing like a six-person
thanksgiving and what we've agreed to do
is
everybody's getting tested on monday of
thanksgiving week
doing nothing for the rest of the week
and assuming we all get
negative tests we'll do an indoor thing
hopefully with windows open sitting far
apart on thursday
um thanksgiving has the remember we
didn't have thanksgiving during the
pandemic last year
and thanksgiving could be a real super
spreader event
nationally uh i think i'm doing nothing
on thanksgiving that's the latest for me
i think i will be reading and
uh catching up on some documentaries
that i've been i've been meaning to but
it is looking
very very ugly yesterday was veterans
day
um a somber day on which we remember
those who
gave time from their lives to serve in
the military
and i i have said this before
think what you want about the missions
our military
is sent on that's a political issue and
i often disagree with the missions our
military is sent on
but i never uh ignore
or miss that we don't have a draft in
this country
and i didn't have to do any military
stuff
because enough people volunteered to do
it now it's a perfectly fair criticism
to say well
the problem is the people volunteering
to do it are not diverse enough
in terms of political background and
whatever you know
you when it's volunteer only you get a
certain type of people in the military
that's a conversation we can have we can
say there are certain folks not well
enough represented
among the military the military is
preying on
uh people of color fine fine
but i remain thrilled
that i didn't have to do anything in the
military
because enough people are volunteering
so it's a somber day you know
etc joe biden tweeted a message of sober
respect
saying quote today we honor the service
of those who have worn the uniform of
the armed forces of the united states
to our proud veterans i will be a
commander-in-chief
who respects your sacrifice understands
your service
and will never betray the values you
fought so bravely to defend that's
biden donald trump meanwhile much like
on veterans day in years past made it
all about himself
and yesterday it was conspiracy theories
about how he really won the election
and how he really won the state of
pennsylvania trump tweeting quote
a guy named al schmidt a philadelphia
commissioner and so-called republican
rhino is being used big time by the fake
news media
to explain how honest things were with
respect to the election in philadelphia
he refuses to look at the mountain of
corruption and dishonesty
we win now aside from
the again completely disrespectful
nature of donald trump doing this on
veterans day
as a reminder the closer we get to 100
of the
pennsylvania vote being counted the
bigger joe biden's lead is actually
getting
it recently surpassed 49 000 votes
onward and beyond
to 50 000 votes inching closer to biden
winning pennsylvania by a
full percentage point putting it out of
recount territory
but it doesn't matter trump doesn't care
veterans day
it's about him it's all about him trump
also tweeting just before the start of
veterans day video from fox news's laura
ingraham show
promoting once again voter fraud
conspiracy theories and this really
shouldn't surprise us because donald
trump has never cared about veterans as
people
remember that during his presidency
which will soon be over
donald trump cared about using the va as
an example
to claim successes many times donald
trump claimed we did veterans choice in
reality that was barack obama's
program from 2014. trump cared about
using soldiers as props
trump even said during the coronavirus
pandemic
that he continued to meet with
military families gold star families
during the pandemic what a great guy
and he even suggested that it might have
been because he continued to meet
with gold star families that he caught
coronavirus maybe from one of them
he actually said that if you can believe
it so what we're ultimately getting to
here is number one this is the last
veterans day on which donald trump
will do this as president unless he runs
in 2024 and wins but we're not going to
really deal with that for the time being
um future veterans days i do imagine
trump will continue to tweet
i did more for veterans when i was
president than anyone else
or something like that he'll still make
it about himself in the future
but the other thing which we're going to
be talking about today and on tomorrow's
program is that this entire voter fraud
thing that donald trump has been pushing
it's working in a few different ways he
has convinced 86
of republicans we're going to look at
the polling tomorrow 86 percent of
republicans now believe
joe biden is not the legitimate winner
of the 2020 election
that's a very serious mind virus for
which we seem to have no vaccine
there's no inoculation i guess critical
thinking and education
are are the inoculation but that is uh
there's a significant dearth of that in
the united states
um and also privately the latest news is
that donald trump
knows he doesn't actually have a path to
victory through
these lawsuits and claims but that he's
doing it as theater and of course the
sick reality of that is there are people
who can't afford it
who are donating to donald trump because
they believe maybe their donations will
help overturn the results
it's sick and we'll deal with all of
that in the next 24 hours
let me know your thoughts about the
veterans day fiasco once again for
donald trump
via twitter where you can find me at d
pacman the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that we're primarily a viewer
and listener supported program if you
just come into our universe over the
last week maybe found the youtube
channel or the audio podcast
you can sign up for a membership and get
an extra show
every day just for you um at
joinpacman.com we have a coupon code
where
it's a fresh start now with joe biden so
the coupon code
fresh start you can use to get a
beautiful discount off of the membership
of your choice at
joinpakman.com this is really funny
we spoke uh we've been speaking this
week and we're going to speak again
in fact about how the world is
increasingly ignoring donald trump media
outlets are focused on the biden
transition
world leaders are welcoming joe biden as
president-elect despite
donald trump not having conceded the
election
this is just amazing british prime
minister boris johnson who i'm not a fan
of politically to be very clear
boris johnson yesterday started
referring to donald trump as the
previous president even though donald
trump still does have a couple months
left
in his presidency and also said it was
refreshing to speak to
president-elect joe biden which is just
perfect and hilarious and if you
if you adjust for british humor and
british temperament
talking about it being refreshing to
speak to joe biden referring to trump as
the previous president
it's pretty spicy stuff let's take a
look and also really funny that the
statement from boris johnson was in
response to a question
from labor mp angela eagle and in her
question to boris johnson angela eagle
couches uh trump's refusal to concede
as embarrassing and dangerous to
american democracy both accurate but
that's the premise and nobody even
thinks to argue with the premise because
of course it's accurate take a look at
this
the prime minister spoke for many of us
when he took a call yesterday to
congratulate
president-elect biden and vice president
elect harris on their emphatic wing in
the
u.s presidential election so does the
prime minister now have any advice
for his erstwhile best friend president
trump whose continuing refusal to accept
the result
is both embarrassing for him and
dangerous for american
democracy prime minister well uh mr
speaker i had
uh and have a good relationship with the
previous president and i
do not resolve uh from that this is the
duty of all british prime ministers have
a good relationship
with the white house but i'm i i'm
delighted
uh to find the many areas uh in which
uh the biden incoming biden harris
administration
uh is able to make common cause with us
it's just hilarious how donald trump
hasn't even conceded
but in either case trump does have the
presidency for two more months
and the british prime minister is
referring to trump as the previous
president
and calling his conversation with the
president-elect
who trump still has not acknowledged as
refreshing now
he may not have meant much by it but
it's poetic
in that much of the world already is
thinking of trump
as the previous president trump is doing
no presidential things
trump has not done any actual
presidential work for months now he's
been campaigning for months
now he's sulking in his office calling
allies and friends and seeing can
anybody give me any
encouraging or good news and we'll be
reporting on that a little bit later
based on
philip rucker's great reporting but
world leaders are just moving on and i
was actually thinking
that all of these discussions about
could donald trump execute a coup
how might donald trump execute a coup
all of that which we've been talking
about i still maintain my position that
the answer is a simple no the latest
claims
uh including from peter alexander from
nbc are that if even trump knows
excuse me even trump knows that he has
no shot at this coup
but that one of the things that will
make it even tougher to steal the white
house if trump tried
is that the world is already looking at
joe biden as if he's president
but ultimately trump failing to steal
the white house
will still have a big impact because
trump
could still delegitimize biden in the
minds of the
al-qaeda types as we call them all over
the country
such that they remain angry throughout
biden's presidency
and obviously that carries with it
significant risk
i don't think trump has a master plan i
don't think trump is some kind of evil
genius where
he's trying to radicalize his supporters
to never acknowledge biden as the
rightful president and maybe even do
violence or whatever i just think trump
doesn't want to lose
but trump continuing to do this even if
he doesn't believe that there's a shot
at overturning the election
which the latest reporting is he doesn't
really believe it
there could be a significant holdover
impact beyond january 20th and as i
referred to earlier
trump has already convinced 86 percent
of his voters
that joe biden did not legitimately win
that is stunning
and so trump's plan simply is an ego
narcissism plan it's the same playbook
he's used his entire life never mind his
entire presidency
blame other people deny that you failed
never apologize never admit defeat
divide
people get people mad and scared and
angry
exaggerate everything that's his plan
but it can have an impact on his
followers and world leaders dealing with
biden as president-elect
is a good thing to push back against
that although it's not like
trump supporters are really willing to
see reason right now
and unfortunately i mean tragically for
the country many of them are never going
to see reason which is why it's
important that joe biden do everything
he can
to just move ahead appoint adults to
positions of power
and that's exactly what joe biden
announced last night with his chief of
staff and i want to talk about that next
so we're waiting to see who will be in
joe biden's cabinet
and there have been a variety of
different names floated some have been
denied some have not been denied
it's very interesting to look at the way
that all goes and ultimately we're going
to know and we'll do a deep dive about
joe biden's cabinet
but as is often the case as a precursor
to selecting your cabinet
joe biden has selected his chief of
staff this is his first
major staff pick of course the vice
president kamala harris
a very important selection which was
made some time ago but
for post-election this is really good
news um
ronald klein is going to be joe biden's
chief of staff
it's just a great choice and everybody
from alexandria ocasio-cortez
to centrist democrats to democratic
consultants everybody says
this is a fantastic choice and i'm i'm
going to tell you a little bit about
ronald klein
but when the bar is not not that claine
isn't a good choice no matter what
but when the bar is so low already
because of donald trump
ronald klein is an adult who is not only
intelligent but he's organized
and he gets things done that's already
going to be much better
than the people that donald trump has
had as chiefs of staff
ronald klein also happened to be barack
obama's ebola czar during the obama
biden administration
and if we want to talk about signals
when
joe biden selects ronald clayne it's a
signal
that he rejects the chaos of the trump
administration
he rejects the idea of these wild loose
cannon unhinged
staffers in a lot of different positions
ron
i'm going to be very up front ronald
klein is going to be a boring chief of
staff
he's going to be a a sensible sober
chief of staff you're not likely to hear
a lot from ronald klein
in terms of cartoonish incidents and
scandals
and fiascos and if you're dealing with a
pandemic as joe biden is going to be
and unfortunately because donald trump
is just done with coronavirus
a very serious pandemic on january 20th
ronald klein is also particularly
qualified because he has experience
dealing with medical outbreaks already
he's a lawyer with a solid legal mind he
has a relatively progressive lien in
terms of what you would expect
for a president like joe biden and he
has the experience that is required at
exactly this time and again
widespread praise uh aoc tweeting quote
good news and an encouraging choice
anti-trump republican steve schmidt
who's not our friend but but
the point is everybody recognizes ronald
klein is a good choice
steve schmidt tweeting looks like the
office of chief of staff
has just been upgraded by 100 gazillion
percent
with the appointment of ronald klein
squad member
congresswoman ayanna presley tweeting
quote having a dedicated humble
hard-working team around you is
everything congratulations ronald klein
encouraged to see you step into this
role and look forward to working
together
senator elizabeth warren tweeting ronald
klein is a superb
choice for chief of staff he understands
the magnitude of the health and economic
crisis
and he has the experience to lead this
next administration
through it ron has earned trust all
across the entire democratic party i
think you get it in washington
you rarely see such unified and nearly
unanimous reaction to any choice for any
position
ever no matter how qualified the person
is he was on the ball
ronald klein was in terms of coronavirus
he wrote back in january
uh nearly 11 months ago a piece in the
atlantic where he said
or the piece was called coronavirus is
coming and trump isn't ready and he
explained
the ways in which donald trump was not
ready so eventually we're going to be
doing a deep dive
on joe biden's cabinet as it comes
together expecting
some names around thanksgiving time but
for now
the person who will be helping biden
choose the cabinet is as close to a
perfect selection as there could be
and contrast it with donald trump's
latest chief of staff
mark meadows who has been running around
trump rallies
with no mask high-fiving people
uh mark meadows caught coronavirus mark
meadows
continued to insist that donald trump
would win even though donald trump
lost and said weeks ago we are not going
to control
the pandemic in what was arguably the
most
defeatist statement we've heard from any
administration official about the
pandemic since the start
so change is very much in the air i
don't expect to agree with every cabinet
choice joe biden makes but
so far this is exactly what you would
want to see now let me say one other
thing
there have been i've been getting a lot
of emails from from people linking me to
articles
some articles saying warren and bernie
are being considered for cabinet
positions
and other articles saying warren and
bernie are being
frozen out of consideration for cabinet
positions
uh with so many rumors floating around
and so many cabinet positions and so
much else to talk about
i don't think there's much value in me
commenting
on speculation about biden's cabinet
when biden chooses his cabinet we will
do a deep dive we will analyze
every single cabinet member some of you
will find it boring some of you will
find
it valuable i think it's very important
and we're we're going to do that to sort
of
set up our understanding of the biden
administration as it comes in
um one of the things i think is
important to think about
uh is that when you select democratic
senators to your cabinet
their senate seats open different states
have different rules
about who and how gets to decide on
their replacement
here in massachusetts we have a
republican governor
currently and as at least as an interim
replacement
to elizabeth warren until there's a
special election
that may mean a republican senator
replaces elizabeth warren
in vermont i actually don't know offhand
exactly how it goes
but while i obviously believe that
elizabeth warren and bernie sanders
would be fantastic cabinet selections
bernie could be secretary of labor
there's other positions he could do
elizabeth warren could be
secretary of education treasury
secretary
you know you could make an argument for
either of them as secretary of commerce
there's no doubt that these are
qualified people i do
and i don't pretend to have an answer to
this question it is it's not rhetorical
it's a real question
are we better served by keeping bernie
and warren
the two most progressive members of the
senate right now
in the senate i think that that's a
completely legitimate question to be
asking
and given that you could pick people
that are arguably as good or almost as
good as them
for cabinet positions although maybe
they would be less recognizable in terms
of name recognition
do we gain more by keeping them in the
senate i think that almost
certainly if warren and bernie leave the
senate to be in biden's cabinet
it's a guarantee that the senate moves
to the right
when you take the two most liberal
members of the senate
and you replace them with people that
are arguably and almost certainly
less liberal the average political
orientation of the senate moves a little
bit to the right and i think that that's
a perfectly
legitimate and important thing to be
talking about and we will discuss it
if democratic senators do make it into
biden's cabinet we will talk about it
if they don't and there are complaints
where is bernie where is warren
we will also talk about it a completely
um uh fundamental
understanding of the reality of what
happens when you take
a democratic senator out uh what happens
to that seat up in the immediate and
also
in the medium to long term when there is
a special election
we'll have more about ronald klein and
biden's cabinet on our instagram page
follow us there at davidpakmanshow and
listen
if you're already on instagram follow me
at david.pacman as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to be joined today by nick
majuli who's the coo
at ritholtz wealth management and also
founder of
dollars and data a data focused personal
finance blog
i've been reading nick's articles for a
long time it's great to have you on nick
hey thanks david appreciate it so okay
to start with i want to talk about
um the biden tax plan a little bit
and what the implications would be how
likely it is to happen but before we
even get into that
as a general principle when we look at
the stock market based on presidential
terms
my personal analysis is that the stock
market tends to return a higher uh
tends to see a higher return under
democratic presidents than republican
presidents
it's not an overwhelming difference so
the first question is
is that distinction relevant to
presidential policy
i do not think it is i think most of
that stuff when you really look at the
data
there's a lot of noise in there and
there was like obviously you're right
that you know democratic presidents tend
to have a slightly higher return
um but it's also kind of biased by
certain things you know you think about
uh
hoover and he was like in great
depression so that kind of messes things
up you think about
you know which time period you want to
use clinton probably had the best
returns ever i know it's the 90s so like
there's all these outliers that kind of
move things around a little bit
um and of course presents do affect
policy which affects markets
i don't think it's it's linked as we
think i think it's probably a lot more
noise unfortunately
would it be fair to say then that
the argument you sometimes hear from the
right that the stock market
is a disaster during democratic
presidents that certainly
isn't true yeah i don't think that's
true i think that the same is also true
on the other side i think it's
disastrous during democratic i think
that's all just
you know political talk coming out one
of the interesting things that you write
in your recent article about the biden
tax plan
is that there certainly is an impact on
one's
personal finances and net worth from
presidents but that it often has much
more to do with tax policy than it does
with the ups and downs of the stock
market and that's a really important
thing to understand
so when you start looking at what the
economy
might be like from a personal finance
standpoint are you focusing actually
more on tax policy than expected stock
stock market movement
yeah i mean for what like for for you
and i and for most people like
what how tax policy changes is going to
affect the dollars coming into your
accounts and
how much dollars you have to pay out to
the government and that's going to have
a much bigger impact than
you know how the market might
necessarily react and of course you know
it's it's one of these things you can't
really know but i know tax policy
for sure changes people's decisions and
behavior in a much bigger way than
i think just minor moves in the stock
market will
so let's talk a little bit about the
biden tax plan what when we
did a dive into it a few weeks ago some
of the notable things
were the change to the corporate uh
income tax rate
going from 21 to 28 percent repealing
the trump tax cuts and you would see
long-term cap gains rates go from about
24
to close to 40 percent you'd see that
top marginal tax rate go
up i think it's about three points to
the pre-trump era and then
and then very importantly right now
social security taxes stop at about
130 dollars in income roughly i don't i
know that's not exactly right
the biden proposal would then reinstate
that twelve point four percent tax
from four hundred thousand dollars and
up completely uncapped which if done
is a massive amount of revenue for for
the government
to start with is it accurate that those
under 400 000 a year in income will not
see an
increase which has been a big topic of
political debate
they should not see an increase in
income tax
now there are if everything in the plan
went through there are certain ways in
which
for example if you're getting property
if you're inheriting property you may
have to pay taxes on that if there's
unrealized gains that you wouldn't have
had to pay
in the you know in the in the current
state of the world so
no income tax is going to be increased
on those people but you might see
um other types of taxes show up given
other life events as i said if you're
inheriting property specifically that's
one that's going to be very
relevant and with that property
inheritance scenario is that
based on the size of the estate or it
could be regardless of the size of the
estate
uh so so there's a little bit of both so
the estate tax
right now allows for 11 point million
11.6 million per single person or 23.2
for a couple you can pass on you know no
estate tax
um and then there's also something
called stepped up basis what that means
is let's say you know
your grandparents had a you know a stock
and they bought apple in like you know
1995 or whatever
and now it's got you know a million
dollars in gains they can when they die
they can pass that on to their heirs
no taxes owed on the gain but if they
get rid of that rule
anyone regardless of who you are you get
that you're going to have to pay the tax
on the difference there and that's also
true of real estate among other things
now
i don't think that's actually going to
pass there's a lot i've talked a lot of
tax professionals about this
like yeah there's no way stepped up base
is going to be completely
gotten rid of because it's a very
complex thing i think the reason they
use it to get rid of stepped up bases is
because
it's just simpler not to have to track
how you improved a real estate property
for over 40 years and
every single home repair and then trying
to track the basis of that as a
nightmare for
for the irs and for individuals so
that's why they just kind of wipe it
clean it's just a little bit easier that
way
so i i want to talk about the likelihood
of any of these different things passing
now to even start that conversation if
democrats don't take
control of the senate with a 50-50 tie
by getting the two georgia runoffs
having kamala harris as the tie-breaking
vote
does any of this stuff pass or is this
all i mean is tax reform even getting
done without a democratic senate
yeah so i don't think it's gonna get i
mean even if they pass it so remember
here's that here's the thing even if
they do get you know
they win the two georgia senate races um
kamal harris you know
uh cast a tie breaking vote you still
have to like argue for all these things
this is like the wish list all these
different things are the wish list but
what's gonna happen is they're gonna go
back and forth with republicans and even
there's gonna be some democrats that say
i don't wanna eliminate this or i don't
wanna
do this so this is really like the best
case scenario just to start and they're
gonna bargain and some of these things
are gonna come and go and i think
for example stepped up basis will
probably be one of the things if i had
to guess that gets kicked out
um first so eve so for now still
continuing in the scenario where
democrats do have the senate but there's
negotiation
i have a really hard time imagining that
social security
will be uncapped from 400 000 and up
and and the reason i say that without
making any moral judgment about it is
that is millions and tens of millions of
dollars in taxes
for for a lot of people and of course
part of it can be avoided by not earning
income through wages and we know about
the way that that can be done
i don't know how that gets passed even
the democratic senate
yeah that's a good point i think yeah
you're right in terms of people would
just
okay immediately companies okay your new
salary cap is
400 thousand dollars and we're going to
pay you all this extra equity income or
this extra thing
they're going to find ways to get money
to you in ways that are not
classified as labor income now i think
some people are probably still just
gonna take the hit and like okay you
know
the employers take six percent i have to
pay six percent whatever but yeah a lot
of people are gonna
shift salaries around and they're gonna
be like oh there's gonna be the 400k
club out there
so i promise that so what's the most
reliable way
i have sometimes financial advisors who
will write to me or they'll call into my
show and they'll say
you know we already know that just
increase increasing income tax rates is
not a great way to capture
um necessarily more revenue because a
lot of really wealthy people
are not earning through wages so then
you've got to maybe look at capital
gains but then there's also different
ways
to avoid paying capital gains taxes or
you can always just kind of wait it out
because with capital gains a lot of it
has to do with when are you realizing
the gain and if you don't like what you
would pay now you can wait for a
different administration
in your experience like if the
government was determined we want to
capture
more of the different types of income
that people are making
what would be the most sort of iron-clad
way to do it
i don't that's a great question i think
this is the question that's like
everyone's trying to figure out how do
you curb inequality really that's really
the question how do you curb inequality
and someone's like okay we can just
raise capital gains like
well let's say let's say you know the
probability of the this whole thing
happening where
you know democrats take over the senate
we let's say it's like a 95
chance right now predict it's putting in
like 24 25 percent so it's a one in four
chance right now
let's say it was 95 percent what you're
gonna see is people are gonna start
realizing the gains now they're gonna
start going through
there's even this thing where in 2010 i
think the estate tax was like zero and
a surprisingly large number of people
happen to die that year so it's like
people will literally change their lives
and somehow just accept the grave to
avoid taxes so
i don't know what's the best way to do
that i wish i had a better answer for
you like
you can do things like that people have
tried wealth taxes but that's like on
the really really you know
rich people but that's tough like how do
you determine wealth how do you you know
capture that how to prevent people from
fleeing there's all sorts of ways to get
at this
i think it's really difficult i mean
capital gains is a start but
it depends how big the jump is i mean
23.8 to 39.6
is a big jump and that's going to change
people's behavior if that were to happen
so then going to the next scenario which
is democrats don't get the senate
is there any tax reform getting done in
the next two years if democrats don't
get the senate
i don't think so i think we're going to
be in gridlock i mean i'm obviously not
an expert at that thing
but i i don't see how it's going to
happen how you know republicans if they
can prevent it from happening
they're happy with what's going on right
now so i think we'll just have more of
the same
so for the average person who makes an
average salary
maybe has access to some kind of
matching contribution
if they're in education maybe it's a 403
b or a 401k uh you know with with
our staff we do a simple ira average
person average
normal person does it make any sense to
be making any changes to what you are
doing
on the basis of who is in the white
house
uh i would say no definitely not i mean
as going back to kind of our earlier
discussion like you know markets rise
markets fall under any sort of president
you can look through history like they
have drawdowns 20 30
drawdowns almost every single president
and markets go up during almost every
present i mean there's obviously
exceptions
you know but i don't think it's the
president's fault that you know oh we
have hyperinflation or we have this or
that like
i don't think it's necessarily always
the president's fault for that type of
thing you know even when fdr took over
in the great depression like
initially like there was a lot of hope
but still the economy was sluggish for a
while and finally got back together so
when the uh coronavirus uh in when the
initial coronavirus dip happened in sort
of like mid-march
the internet was riddled with hot takes
about sell now or buy more
options or wait buy back in in a month
this sort of stuff now my view having
read everything from ben
graham a hundred years ago and
understanding
what warren buffett's perspective is and
the great jack bogle
and so on and so forth my view has
always been
i don't think i can time the market i
don't think i'm slick enough i've got a
full-time job
and understanding that each year
a huge portion of the gain comes from
a very small number of trading days and
if you're timing
you could miss one of those days and
miss out on a lot of the return for a
particular year not to mention there are
tax implications to buying and selling
etc
are there exceptions to that where it
makes sense to either try to time the
market based on the news cycle
or legislatively or in any other way
i would generally say no i would never
try to do something like that there are
certain quantitative models that use
sort of a trend following to look at
like 200-day moving averages and that
but i don't want to get into all the
technicality of that there are
some that do and even those like a lot
of those models which traditionally have
worked for the last 20 years
failed during covet because it was such
a quick decline and it came back so
quickly
that quick v recovery that the models
had never seen anything like that and so
they weren't they didn't have any data
to prepare for that to jump back in so
you see a lot of people that are
actually
the best in the business at trent
following you know got a little bit
burned this year unfortunately
um but that's kind of that's what
happens you know it's just that's that's
the nature of markets
so briefly just talking about corporate
tax now as we've been talking all about
kind of kind of personal financial um
there's this idea again in the biden tax
plan of raising the corporate income tax
rate from 21 to 28
now a lot of small business owners
including me uh set up as an s
corporation
all of our income is passed through in
other words the the business itself is
paying some
stat to quote donald trump some
statutory amount which i think in
massachusetts is like 450
or something like that and then
basically i'm getting a k1
as an owner and i'm paying tax on my
personal income taxes so
the corporate tax rate i don't believe
actually affects me so it's kind of a
two-part question
are small businesses affected by the
corporate tax rate who really is
affected by that
yeah so that's that it depends i mean
you're right
there's a lot a lot of income especially
amongst you know higher income families
is
coming through partnerships and smaller
businesses not necessarily like
you know corporate tax is going to be
for i think much larger businesses
so it will affect certain people but i
think as you said a lot of people have
smaller businesses they use
pass-throughs a lot of law firms or
pass-throughs or partnerships things
like that so it's going to affect some
people
um and it'll probably affect the stock
market in some ways that were to come to
pass because obviously corporate tax
means you know less profits so just
simple as that so
um but yeah once again this is how
likely is this
as of right now it doesn't seem too
likely one of the things that's never
made sense to me and i've asked a lot of
economists about this you hear this
talking point
from businesses if you raise the
corporate tax rate
it will be bad for the economy and it
will be bad
in general because businesses won't
invest in growing their business
to me it seems completely
counterintuitive because if i'm a
business owner
and i can take profits at a 20 tax rate
or take profits at a 30 tax rate
avoiding a 30
tax seems like something i would be more
inclined to do and the way you avoid tax
of course is by making capital
investments so
if you apply a demand side approach
wouldn't a higher corporate tax rate
encourage investment in a business
because you're incentivized to avoid
what is a higher rate of tax
yeah i mean you that's one way to look
at it um you can also say like okay well
if my taxes some you know who doesn't
want like a do you want
you get it you want 70 cents if you want
80 cents like oh i'll take 70 since
you're gonna give it to me right so like
you're still making money either way um
i do think the logic for that argument
is correct but it has to be at a much
higher rate i think going 21 to 28
it's like where are you on the curve
that's always the question this is the
big debate like
if we went from obviously 21 to 100 you
can see obviously that that would
completely devastate business
there but where is that how big is it
measuring that that's really the crux of
the argument and people will argue on
both sides and i think
you know if it was clear we would just
know it we wouldn't be debating it
that's the problem a lot of these
debates the reason our debates is
because
it's not clear-cut in the data and if it
was clear-cut we just wouldn't debate it
anymore i think that's kind of how this
works yeah and there's a lot of i think
there's a lot of bad faith actors on
both sides with these issues that want
to
create edge cases that nobody's arguing
for like for example
people against the 15 minimum wage will
often say
well if 15 is better because people have
more money what about 150
and of course nobody's talking about 150
150 wouldn't be an equilibrium wage 150
would not be
a wage that's in line with cost of
living and i i'm wondering if you also
think that to really discuss this stuff
we have to eliminate these kind of straw
man edge cases and think about the the
meat of the curve as you're talking
about
not the extremes yeah i don't think you
can use exceptions to make to try and
make rules or argue rules it's really
tough there are
obviously for example one of the biggest
things in the investment literature is
this whole idea
of the black swan it's like oh you look
at this average distribution and the
exception
is the most important thing because the
exception changes everything so
i kind of agree with some of that logic
sometimes but sometimes it's also a
straw instead of
when are you talking about are you
talking about in a risk context are you
talking about in a minimum wage context
obviously yeah like why not 150
because that makes obviously no sense
like there's too many jobs where the
equilibrium wage is just
far too low compared to 150 an hour
so i completely see both sides of it um
but yeah i agree that you should try to
like
where's the meat of the distribution i
think it's a good way of looking at it
we've been speaking
with nick majuli who is coo at ritholtz
wealth management also founder of
of dollars and data i might have missed
one of the of your founder of
of dollars and data yes uh personal
finance blog that i subscribe to nick
really appreciate your time and having
you on
yes thank you appreciate it the david
pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump's press secretary kaylee
mckennany has
humiliated herself again maybe for the
last time if fox news
stops having her on although my sense is
she'll still continue humiliating
herself for a couple more months
kaylee mckennany does this thing which
is completely
absurd it's it's absurd in like an evil
genius way
which is she has different personas
sometimes kaylee mckennany is white
house press secretary
speaking in her official role as white
house press secretary
sometimes she is a trump campaign
senior advisor and then sometimes she's
just a private person
and uh i i know that this may be
difficult for a lot of folks
who expect logic and reason to
understand but when kaylie does her
press briefings which she hasn't done in
a very long time
that's very clear she is white house
press secretary
very clear-cut speaking to us as the
representative for donald trump
now just before the election she started
appearing on fox news
pretty frequently under a different
title
and you would see under her name it
would say trump 2020
senior advisor it's already weird
because she's
officially a white house staffer and
then
last week at that completely ridiculous
press conference where she said it was
all
stolen biden didn't win anything trump
won everything and held up pieces of
paper
she said hi i'm kaylee mckennany i'm
here in my personal capacity
it's like dr jekyll and mr hyde that
that sort of thing
well this morning kaylee shows up on fox
news and you just have to see this first
of all
i guess in order to try to keep things
kosher from the standpoint of the hatch
act
brian kilmeade actually says kaylee has
two roles
and today she's here not as press
secretary but as a campaign person take
a look
kaylee mcinnady joins us she's got a
dual role here she's on as the trump
2020 campaign advisor uh kate so it's
it's almost like
brian kilmeade was told make sure to
mention this
and you i mean i i don't know how you
tell the difference maybe when she wears
her diamond cross
necklace she's there as press secretary
and when she wears her gold cross
necklace that's when she's the campaign
advisor
sort of like superman when he has the
glasses on it's clark kent
when the glasses come off it's superman
i don't know but it's all wacky
but then this is where it gets just
beyond satire
brian kilmeade says you know joe biden
isn't getting the presidential daily
briefing uh he did win
it's a national security issue and
kaylee says
now that's a question for the white
house she is the white house
spokesperson as press secretary but
today we have to pretend she's a
different character
she's merely a lowly campaign advisor
check this out it's wild
a republican he said listen give joe
biden the presidential daily brief after
all senator
harris gets gets she's on the intel
committee she's getting
she has high high level security access
has the president consider that
i haven't spoken to the president about
that that would be a question
more for the white house but i will say
that all laws are being followed
with regard to an expected transition
though we expect to continue on
as the trump administration we will see
how our litigation goes
when we say um how stupid do they think
we are
they think their followers and fox news
viewers
are very stupid and this is
indistinguishable
from parody and even though we've
already heard
that trump knows he can't win and he's
doing this entire thing as
theater and you know taking money from
people in doing so
kaylee mckennany will not close the door
on donald trump pushing for republican
legislators
to try to essentially invalidate the
election results
by selecting trump electors
this is the electoral college strategy
we talked about about six weeks ago
and the idea is take a state that biden
won by the popular vote like for example
wisconsin because biden won
what they're supposed to do is send
biden electors
uh to cast their official electoral
votes for joe biden but
if you can find a state with a state
legislature that is republican that
might be willing to just
interfere theoretically the state
legislature could send
trump electors even though joe biden
wins the popular vote in that state
that's what they're
asking about here and kaylee mckennany
won't rule it out
controlled state legislatures would then
because they would not be certified
would then appoint pro-trump electors
who would swing the electoral college in
his favor
it's unclear exactly how seriously the
campaign is taking that
how seriously is the campaign
considering that
well constitutionally that is an
accurate argument it is the state
legislatures that choose the electors
but right now
uh they're zeroed in completely on
litigation and
so there she is not ruling it out but we
we might discuss that more
i've already talked about it uh and and
of course
no good trump voter fraud segment
would be complete until somebody holds
up papers for the camera
and kaylee mckennany also doing that fix
their ballot so we have a number of
affidavits
from voters who were not told to fix
their ballot while their democrat
counterparts in seven counties
were so that's kaylee mckennany uh trump
campaign staffer
not there yeah i know you i know she's
white house press secretary
she wasn't there as white house press
secretary so when she was asked
questions
about trump that she doesn't want to
answer
she says oh that would be a question for
the white house like maybe
for the white house press secretary
which is her
these are wild times that we are living
through
i am very ready for it to end and we're
getting closer we're getting closer and
even donald trump seems to be
acknowledging that
we've already discussed that donald
trump uh privately
knows he can't win tomorrow i'll have a
more detailed report on that for you
the the report from peter alexander is
that
trump realizes that he has no path to
overturning the results of the election
but he's doing it as theater the
lawsuits the fights the
uh seek seeking and receiving financial
contributions it's
theater but how is donald trump really
doing
the speculation of course is that donald
trump
is clearly damaged and triggered
he's barely been seen in public since
losing he did one press briefing last
week where he took no questions simply
saying
i won he briefly showed up yesterday at
a wreath-laying ceremony
for veterans day and because
we know about donald trump's narcissism
and being a sore loser and egomaniac
never apologizing never admitting defeat
one would imagine that donald trump is
not taking this particularly well
well the washington post philip rucker
was on msnbc
yesterday and he's covered this white
house really well for years he has a
number of uh of sources inside the trump
administration
and philip rucker says that the reality
is trump is quite fragile
emotionally right now take a listen to
this don't think it'll come as a
surprise to anybody
we haven't heard from the president this
week
we saw him today what's your reporting
on where he is on his personal journey
well brian his emotional state is quite
fragile we've not
seen or heard from the president in
several days with the exception of this
morning on a rainy day in washington he
went out to arlington
uh national cemetery to lay a wreath uh
in observance of veterans day
uh but he has not been doing much uh
governing as best we can tell he's
actually fighting hard to keep a job
that he doesn't seem
uh content to do at the moment rather
he's been
lighting up the phones from the white
house he's been calling
uh friends advisors allies uh in in what
one official describes to my colleagues
ashley parker josh stasi and myself uh
as a search for good news he's just
casting about for somebody to tell him
something good
uh so he can hold on to hope that he
might still win this election
uh even though the the reality the
numbers are are clearly against him and
he's starting to recognize that
so much so that he's talking about
running again uh in 2024 which if he
held on to any
uh any sense that he was that these
election results were going to be
overturned and he would be declared
the victor then he would not be talking
about a 2024 campaign
uh but here we are that that is what
he's talking about
uh these last few days so it all makes
sense quite fragile
barely leaving the white house doing no
governing calling people searching for
good news to see if anybody might
give him some good news and thinking
about running again in 2024. so i guess
trump's feelings are hurt
but remember it's their side that always
says facts don't care about your
feelings
isn't it time to buck up and accept the
facts
and this isn't just trump this is the
entire uh right
and say that he lost they lost that's it
and there were i saw this hilarious
tweet yesterday
who was it that's it was like a both
sides thing
oh it was uh howard kurtz who i think
now does like a media analysis show on
fox news
which is hilarious in principle but
howard kurtz tweeted
both sides see and on one side
you had trump alleging that he really
won
and then and refusing to allow the biden
transition to officially start
and then the example of the left was
that a whoopi goldberg i guess said
trump trump supporters have to suck it
up saying look both sides
hold on a second one side is the current
administration
refusing to accept that they lost a
presidential election
and interfering with the
president-elect's transition that's one
side
what you're comparing it to to say both
sides are doing it is
whoopi goldberg saying random trumpists
should just accept that trump lost
both sides give me a break and i i was
again reminded of that right wing
of refrain facts don't care about your
feelings these are facts guys
trumpists are going to need to suck it
up and accept the fact that donald trump
lost and at the same time
at some point trump is going to have to
accept that joe biden is president of
the united states
it could take months into biden's
presidency before donald trump
accepts it now i do want to talk about
one other thing i've not heard a lot of
discussion about this
we do have a national security
vulnerability right now that has
developed
the reality is that donald trump really
hasn't been doing his job as president
for a long time
punted on coronavirus he's almost
exclusively been campaigning for months
there really hasn't been a president for
a while
but we now have a more acute national
security issue because
trump is doing no work trump reportedly
hasn't been even receiving his
presidential daily briefing
and when trump was getting the pdb he
didn't pay attention
he didn't read it sometimes he would get
distracted by a tv with fox news in the
back of the room
but donald trump is also not allowing
the president-elect joe biden to start
receiving the presidential daily
briefing now
ideally normally in every other
transition
the president is getting the
presidential daily briefing
and the president-elect also starts
getting it and that way you have a
smooth transition when joe biden comes
into office on january 20th
he's aware and up to speed about
everything that's going on terrorism
national security threats etc
we have a situation right now where for
at least two months
no one is really getting the
presidential daily briefing trump is
president he's not getting it
biden is president-elect he's not
getting it and on top of this we have
the report from philip rucker
that donald trump's emotional state is
quite fragile right now
so if you're a rogue nation if you're an
adversary if you're an enemy if you're a
terrorist organization
you know there is a window of
vulnerability here for the next two
months
and maybe for some period after as joe
biden
gets settled and gets up to speed on
everything the u.s
is likely more vulnerable than usual
this is an invitation to do bad things
for lack of a better term
it is globally known you need no sources
you don't need to eavesdrop on anything
it is globally known that right now
there's a total absence of leadership on
national security
nobody's getting the pdb at the highest
levels of government
anyone who would want to do us harm can
just turn on tv and realize what's going
on
very disturbing all because of donald
trump's fragile ego
and lack of willingness to formally
admit defeat and sign off
on joe biden starting to get the
presidential daily briefing it's
disgusting
i got a voicemail today um at 2192 david
p
asking about impending trump pardons
take a listen
hey dude this is jeff from colorado yes
uh now that
uh biden has won uh presumptively one
um i think you've said in the past that
you think trump will probably
be pardoning all sorts of uh his
criminal friends
and i'm wondering uh two things i guess
what else
do you think he's going to do in this
lame duck period
and in particular do you think he's
going to pardon himself
okay so at this point
there is no doubt that donald trump is
going to pardon a bunch of his criminal
friends
the stuff about you know trump resigning
so pence can pardon him preemptively i i
don't think it's hugely likely
but that's partially because it would be
such a crazy event
um it's certainly conceivable that it
could happen
i think there's a good chance trump does
what he's been doing for the last week
for the rest of his term which is
nothing and michael cohen his former
lawyer said he thinks trump will leave
the white house
for the christmas holiday and just never
go back to dc um that he won't be at
biden's inauguration
i don't know but there is no doubt that
the pardoning is going to happen
of other people of other people trump
pardoning all sorts of people
we have a great bonus show for you today
make sure to get instant access
by grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or
listen to an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes you can try blinkist for
free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video